-It is time for a game of
"Random Instrument Challenge."
Here we go!
-♪ "Random Instrument
Challenge" ♪
-And playing with me is
the one, the only Pete Davidson,
ladies and gentlemen!
-♪ "Random Instrument
Challenge" ♪
-Pete Davidson right --
That's what I'm talking about.
Thank you for being here.
Thanks for playing
with us, buddy.
Alright, here's how
this works, okay?
We're going to have a bunch of
instruments over here
that neither of us know
how to play.
And on your turn, you will
pick a card from the board,
which will give you
a name of a random song.
-Okay.
-Alright?
Then Tariq will pick from a bag.
He will give us
a random instrument.
You'll then have to play
the song with that instrument.
If The Roots can guess what
song you're playing,
you get a point.
-Okay.
-Enough rules? It makes sense?
-It sounds good. Hi, Roots.
-Alright, alright.
Since I'm the host,
I'll go first, I guess.
Alright, which number, guys?
We have an audience.
This is exciting.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
Alright.
It's such a great audience that
they all just went, "4!"
-"4." Yeah.
-No one had any other number.
Out of all the numbers,
everyone just said, "4!"
No, that's good. I got you.
I heard everyone loud and clear.
Okay. Alright.
Tariq, what instrument
will I be playing?
-Let's see here.
Oh. You're going to be playing
a long, wooden flute.
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
-Okay.
-[ Laughs ]
-I have no idea.
Alright.
[ Breathes deeply ]
How does this come out?
Alright.
This is not even a normal flute.
This is like some weird ---
-It's a long one.
-I know.
I understand it's a long one.
but this is like a...
That's not the weird part.
-Oh, okay.
-I've seen
the long flutes before.
I just...
[ Clears throat ]
I own one, actually.
It's just the bamboo one
is what gets me.
Alright.
I have no idea where to even...
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, alright. Okay.
Alright. Everybody,
alright, come on.
Okay, here we go.
Alright. Alright.
[ Whooshing ]
Alright.
30 seconds on the clock.
[ Whooshing ]
-Is it "God Save the Queen?"
-No. Why would you guess
"God Save the --" No.
It's not a punk-rock song.
-Start from the top.
-I was.
[ Whooshing ]
[ Buzzer ]
-Whatever, man.
"Party in the U.S.A.,"
Miley Cyrus!
-Oh, man.
-Turn it up!
-Wait. That was "Par--" Okay.
-I was going to say that.
-Hey, that wasn't fair.
-[ Laughs ]
No, it's not fair. Thank you.
I appreciate it, Pete.
-Yeah, man.
-Pete, you're up, buddy.
Pick a song from the board.
Yeah.
-Which one do you guys...
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-There you go.
-8? I heard 7. I heard 7.
[ Shouting continues ]
Alright, alright!
-Now they're getting --
-Alright.
What do I got to do?
Which instrument?
-Okay.
Oh, yeah.
You got to play the Omnichord.
-What the [bleep] is that?
[ Laughter ]
-You can't say --
-I'm sorry.
-You can't say the F-word.
-I'm gonna guess it's this guy,
the accordion-looking
thing, right?
-The big-ass thing?
-Yeah.
♪♪
-Wait.
-No, no, no.
The Omnichord is this thing.
-This? Really? Yeah?
-That's a microphone.
-I thought that was
a CPAP machine.
-Okay. And this thing's just on?
Okay, guys.
-Come on, Pete.
You got this, buddy.
[ Synthesizer playing ]
-Okay.
-So far...
-Wait.
-It's weird.
-I think it's broken.
[ Laughter ]
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
-It's kind of dope.
-Wait. Is it going to stop?
[ Synthesizer continues ]
Wait.
-"Happy Birthday to You?"
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
-Wait.
-Pete, maybe slide the thing up
and down, that white thing.
[ Buzzer ]
If you slide that thing
up and --
No, the other thing.
-What thing?
No, we should actually
figure this out,
'cause that's not cool.
-It looks cool, but --
-Alright, it broke.
I don't know what it was.
It was "Brick House."
-Oh, man!
♪ She's a brick...♪
Yeah. Alright. Yeah.
-Thanks, guys.
-Dude, we got to go on
concert -- on tour together.
It's gonna be great.
-We're sick, dude.
-Alright, my turn. Here we go.
10?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
"5!"
Love it -- 5.
Okay.
-Oh, yes!
-You got this.
-Alright, what instrument
do I got?
I know the song.
-Eh, it's a new song.
-Okay, okay.
Now you got to play it
on the theremin.
That's that guy.
-That's the cool one.
That's where you just go
like this, right?
♪♪
-Are you sure
you know this song?
-Yes, I know this song.
Here we go.
-Okay.
[ Humming ]
[ Humming continues ]
[ Screeching ]
-There you go.
Unh!
[ Screeching continues ]
-"Up" by Cardi B?
-Yes! How did you...
[ Dinging ]
♪♪
-Wow, that's amazing.
-It is amazing. Yeah, thank you.
That was unbelievable.
How did you get "Up"?
-That was cool, man.
Alright, that was pretty fun.
Alright, Pete.
-I was like, "I don't know what
it is, but it sounds great."
What do you guys...
[ Indistinct shouting ]
1? Okay.
Oh, come on. Alright.
What do I got?
-Upright bass.
-Upright bass?
-Yeah.
-Is that that big one?
-Yeah, it's the upright one.
-You can do this, man.
You got this.
♪♪
-Alright.
-This is great.
-This is just something
I thought I'd never
have to do in my life.
♪♪
-Lower.
-Okay, hold on.
Lower? You think lower?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Okay.
-Higher, higher.
[ Laughter ]
-This audience
is very interactive.
-Yeah. Okay.
Wait. Hold on.
♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
-What was it? Do that again.
-Yeah, a little more.
Yeah, a little more.
-Alright, one more time.
-It's, like, something
on a soundtrack.
-"Toxic" by Britney Spears?
-We're in the realm.
-Oh, crap!
No, it was "Like a Virgin"
by Madonna.
-Aah!
-Oh!
[ Cymbal crashes ]
-Why did you say "Aah,"
like you were close?
That was --
-That was good.
-That was good, absolutely.
Madonna would be proud.
Alright, this last one,
let's join forces and do a song.
[ Imitating upright bass ]
I heard it.
I heard it in my head.
-Yeah, I heard it.
-We're going to both try
and play the same song
at the same time
and work together
to get The Roots to guess.
-Okay.
-Let's join forces.
Here we go.
Pick the song.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
Yeah, let's go for 10.
And I can see it, too,
'cause it's me and you.
-Oh, this is a cool one.
-Okay, yeah, yeah, we got this.
Right? We got this.
-Yeah, for sure.
-Tariq, what instruments
are we playing?
-Guitarrón.
-The what?
-The guitarrón?
-That's all you.
You're a guitar man.
-The guitarrón and the melodica.
-The little piano?
-Yeah.
-Alright. Cool.
We just do the chorus, right?
-Yes, exactly, right?
-Yeah.
Okay. I got to blow into this?
-Alright.
-Pete, it's --
-I know, I know.
Let me guess --
it's your first time, right?
-No, pick it up.
-Hold on.
-You can pick it up.
-Dude, it's not a drug test.
It's not a drug test.
-You can pick it up.
-I can pick it up?
-How he starts his cars.
-Okay.
-Ready?
-Alright, wait.
-You got it.
-I have never seen something
happen to this guy
where it's like --
-It's COVID-friendly.
-You got to kind of
hollow out your chest?
Wait. Alright?
-One, two, three.
-Two, three.
♪♪
Let's start it from
the top again.
Ready? One, two, three.
♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, come on!
-Wait. Just one more time.
One, two, three.
♪♪
-That was good!
-"I Love Rock 'n Roll"?
No, "I Want You to Want Me."
-Yes! Cheap Trick.
One, two, three.
♪♪
Yeah, you got...
-Right? Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Pete Davidson, everybody!
More with Pete after this!